1.3 billion years ago in a galaxy far
far away to black holes merged as they
violently spiraled into each other they
created travelling distortions in the
fabric of space-time gravitational waves
in the last tenth of a second the energy
released in these waves was 50 times
greater than the energy being released
by everything else in the observable
universe combined that's like an
awe-inspiring kind of energy after
spreading out through the universe at
the speed of light for over a billion
years the waves reached earth where they
stretched and squeezed space such that
two light beams traveling in
perpendicular pipes were put slightly
out of step allowing humans to detect
the existence of gravitational waves for
the first time
that's a simple enough story to tell but
when I found out when I went to visit
professor Rana at Akari at Caltech is
that it hides the absurdity of just what
was required to make that detection
there's a lot of things about
gravitational waves which are absurd
[Music]
that's it yeah the main problem with
detecting gravitational waves is that
they're tiny they stretch in the
squeezed space by just one part in 10 to
the 21 that's the equivalent of
measuring the distance between here and
Alpha Centauri and then trying to
measure variations in that distance that
are the width of a human hair to detect
such tiny Wiggles you have to measure
over as large a distance as possible
which is why the arms of the
interferometers are 4 kilometers and
even with arms this long gravitational
waves vary the length of the arms by at
most 10 to the minus 18 meters so the
detector has to be able to reliably
measure distances just one
ten-thousandth the width of a proton
it's the tiniest measurement ever made
so how is it possible to measure that
considering all the other sources of
vibrations and noise in the environment
like earthquakes traffic and electrical
storms well for one thing the mirrors
are the smoothest ever created they
weigh 40 kilograms or 90 pounds and are
suspended by silica threads just twice
the thickness of a hair to isolate them
from their environment and even then the
only way to be certain not to be tricked
by environmental noise was to build two
detectors far apart from each other in
reasonably quiet locations that allows
you to distinguish between the local
noise which would appear at only one
site and gravitational waves which would
pass through both sites almost
simultaneously
I'm in a building that contains a 1 to
100 scale of LIGO the gravitational wave
detector the next challenge is the
lasers there's a lot of stuff you need a
laser that can provide one and exactly
one wavelength you can imagine if your
laser wavelength is changing and you're
trying to use interference of light
waves to make this measurement it's
never going to work because it's
something like trying to measure this
distance but your ruler stick is
constantly changing back and forth you
can't tell how many inches this is all
this equipment at least 3/4 of it
all we're trying to do is make the laser
more stable and by the end of the day
what we've achieved is something which
has a stability of one part in 10 to the
20 what does that mean that's a hundred
billion of a trillion that's kind of
what we end up with the best lasers for
this purpose have a wavelength of 1064
nanometers that's infrared light but
this presents a problem how can you
measure 10 to the minus 18 with 10 to
the minus 6 yeah lengths of light yes I
wish more people would ask this question
it's great for this animation to show
such a large shift in the wavelength but
the reality is it's only one trillionth
of a wavelength that the arms are
shifting in length it seems obvious that
you can measure half a wavelength
because that'll cause the light to
interfere with itself yeah but that's
fully that'll go from completely dark to
completely bright so are you looking at
like slightly darker and slightly
brighter yeah yeah and the limit here to
how good we can measure this difference
between dark and bright has to do with
the the fact that the light is discrete
it comes in discrete chunks which are
called photons the variation in the
number of photons hitting the mirrors at
any instant due to this quantum
uncertainty is proportional to the
square root of the total number of
photons what this means is the more
photons you use the smaller the
uncertainty gets as a fraction of the
total this is why the laser power in the
arms is one megawatt that is enough
energy to power a thousand homes in a
light beam and a megawatt you know
boom it won't even rip your head off you
just vaporised to be just a smoking
stump even with a perfect laser and one
megawatt of power anything the light
hits would interfere with it even the
air so all the air in the arms of the
detectors had to be eliminated and it
took 40 days to pump down to just a
trillionth of atmospheric pressure and
the tubes were heated up to the
temperature of an oven to expel any
residual gases they pumped out enough
air to fill up two and a half million
footballs making it the second largest
vacuum in the world after the Large
Hadron Collider now here's something
most people don't think about which is
that gravitational waves stretch
space-time so light traveling through
that space should be stretched as well
if everything is stretching how do you
know anything is strapped do you know
anything is stretching that's the
conundrum it doesn't make any sense to
say this whole thing is bogus shut it
down I would send a laser beam down this
tube and then wait for it to come back
and then I would say well nothing
happened because this space got
stretched and the laser wavelength got
stretched it's it looks the same if it
got stretched or not stretched they make
any sense well it's sort of a matter of
timing is how it works so the amount of
time it takes for light to go down this
tube and comes back is very short
however the wave the gravitational wave
when it comes through it's doing this
slow thing like this noise I made which
is low it's this it's a slow stretching
it's only a hundred times per second and
it's true when the wave comes through
the light which is in there it actually
does get stretched and then that part
doesn't doesn't do the measurement for
us but now that the space has stretched
that laser light is I come and gone it's
out of the picture we're constantly
shooting the laser back into the system
so the new fresh light now goes through
there and has to travel a bigger
distance than the light before and so by
looking at how this interference changes
with time and keeping the laser
wavelength from the laser itself fixed
we're able to do the measurement so what
was needed to detect gravitational waves
well a megawatt of laser power to
minimize shot noise of exactly one
wavelength because we're trying to
measure just a trillionth of that wave
continually inserted to replace older
light that's been stretched and squished
in the world's second largest vacuum
chamber at just a trillionth of
atmospheric pressure hitting the
smoothest mirrors ever created suspended
by silica threads at two distant sites
to eliminate noise with four kilometer
long arms to increase the magnitude of
gravitational waves to just a thousandth
of the width of a proton you know what
we already do daily in here is what I
would have said is impossible if you'd
asked me about it 20 years ago one of
the things that was most interesting for
me to learn was what is limiting the
sensitivity of the detectors today and
it turns out it is quantum mechanics and
essentially you can think of it like a
Heisenberg uncertainty principle we've
got two things and together their
uncertainty has to be bigger than a
certain value luckily for us we're only
trying to measure one thing here we're
not trying to measure two things at the
same time all we want to know is how
much more the disarm gets stretched from
that arm and that's that's the key point
which people did not understand until
recently the way to build these systems
is such that they're extremely good in
measuring one thing and that all of the
uncertainty which comes from quantum
mechanics is completely crammed into
this other thing that we don't care
about I feel like we're getting down to
these levels of nature where it seems
like Nature doesn't want you to go any
further but through our ingenuity we're
figuring out ways to engineer quantum
noise I think that's such a remarkable
concept and I look forward to the
results that it's going to bring I think
the next logical step is to go from two
signals to detecting all the black holes
in the universe all of the time it's not
like an alien civilization level of
technology it's just we have to do a lot
better than what we're doing now but
it's I see it sort of within
within our grasp
[Music]
[Music]